hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar anti-body
titration for flow cytometric analysis
of extracellular vesicles are self-based
protocols up to the task i'm susie
valdez of labyrinth and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth and brought to you by miltonis
biotech now we encourage you to
participate today by submitting as many
questions as you may have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
now this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
so please click on that continuing
education window at the bottom of your
screen to obtain those credits i'd now
like to welcome our speaker dr desmond
pink the chief scientific officer of
gnostics inc doesn't welcome you may now
begin your presentation sir
thank you
good day everyone uh
welcome
today i just want to
give sort of an agnostic approach to
antibody titration and how it's used in
the analysis of extracellular vesicles
or small particles in general using
microflow
so just some disclaimers i'm the founder
and employee agnostics not received any
compensation from miltoni for this
presentation and miltoni has not
directly directed any of the analysis or
censored any data from this presentation
views are my own and do not necessarily
reflect the views of multani biotech
so i just want to introduce the team uh
sort of this is uh my research team and
my clinical team michael and diana
juliana and argha
also i'd like to introduce asia riegers
he's helped me do some of the imaging
flow cytometry here in this presentation
and of course
the big boss john lewis
so what i want to do today is sort of
give you an overview of some of the
things that i've found over the years
are important to consider
when performing antibiotic antibody
titration and it should be
a fundamental exercise that you do in
your lab especially when you're
undertaking any
new cohorts that you're going to be
analyzing any new reagents
basically it should be something that
you do all the time
so we'll touch upon some samples
reagents a tiny bit about instruments
we'll do a lot about the analysis and
i'll also talk about some of the
remaining questions that are always sort
of popping up
but one thing that i really want to do
is really balance the theory with some
practical real world experience so that
i can put my money where my mouth is
so starting off so why even bother
titrating antibodies and i asked this
question because i think we're all
taught you know titrate your antibodies
but i've had so many collaborators and
so many students that i've worked with
who
just simply have never either heard
about it or don't know how to do it
properly
or even appreciate why you should do it
so the classic answer is to basically
get the best fluorescent measurement you
want to maximize the signal
while reducing the noise
so in a prior life i did a lot of
microscopy so what i'm showing you here
is sort of my visual interpretation of
what
titration would look like for
microscopes
so this is an image of a highly
vascularized tumor
with an antibody not titrated
titrating it without the absence of your
treatment or your drug we can actually
see a lot more clarity here now we can
actually see the vascular system
permeating into the tumor
now
actually you know optimizing your
antibody titration allows you to see
very small changes
or rare events you know you're talking
about full cytometry
when you have your
antibodies properly titrated so again
not titrated a lot of signal in the
background
titrate your drug you actually minimize
that that noise and then it allows you
to see
very small changes
so again one of the other parts of why
even bother
is your data reproducibility i mean
blaming it on antibodies and
you know the discord in
being able to validate
whole studies has been blamed on
antibody irreplaceability for a number
of years this is three um nature
articles spanning the last five or six
years and this topic comes up
all the time
and one of the things that really comes
out is quality
and
it's not sexy doing an antibody
titration is not the pinnacle of
research
but it is crucial
so
whose responsibility is it
vendors need to be able to provide you
the antibiotic product that they state
in the in the vial but the illness is
really on the researcher to make sure
that that antibody performs as you
expect it to perform
so what are companies doing so
uh because miltonios is sponsoring this
i'm gonna plug them for this and
miltonia like other companies they have
introduced programs over the last number
of years where they're doing recombinant
antibody uh production and what does
that allow us to do it allows us to
decrease
interfering binding
on the fc regions allows to allows us to
improve lots a lot reproducibility
the purity is better
and it allows us a bit more flexibility
if we're going to engineer new
components
so all of these things really help
consistency
over the course of your project
especially if you're a master's student
or phd student or a trainee and you're
doing
studies that span years
so the question is when should you
titrate and i think everybody wants to
say you know the first time you buy an
antibody you should always titrate it
and that's true first time you use a
particular clone
or conjugate obviously you need to
titrate this
we've also found that if you have
prolonged storage
especially if you're in a lab and you
don't know who else has been using it
if you have a summer student that comes
in and potentially contaminates
the stock
just check it
run a simple titration it'll
save it'll save a lot of headaches
uh if you get new or suspicious
shipments of your antibody so by
suspicious shipments i basically mean
you know i live in edmonton alberta
canada and at times it can be 35 degrees
celsius in the summertime and minus 35
degrees celsius in the winter time so
there are chances that our antibodies
could freeze
so if you get a weird looking shipment
titrate your antibodies it will tell you
if it's working properly if you get
shipments with different lot numbers
by trade
if you have a long time between orders
even if it's the same company same clone
the same conjugate
you realize that antibody companies are
going to make big batches of these
antibodies
and they're going to be sitting in bats
purified proteins will degrade over time
so
take that extra you know couple of hours
and titrate to make sure that your
antibodies behaving the same way
if you're getting it from a different
company
it'd be the same clone same conjugate um
you don't know what's happened if that
antibody is coming from the distributor
from the supplier to a different
distributor you don't know if there's
been weird shipment anomalies so just
take your you know take that half
morning and do it and again if you get
suspicious data so we always try to have
positive controls for our antibodies
and
if your positive controls
fail
and even after you've done that the
titration like weeks beforehand go back
and just do a quick one and it'll tell
you a lot of information
so we've experienced pretty much all of
these
and well i'm not going to show data for
all of these if if you guys want to see
data just give me a shout and i can
provide data for this
so what does a titration analysis look
like if you google antibody titration
these are pretty much the typical graphs
that are going to come up for pictures
that are going to come up
and these are fine
this reflects what you're going to see
in cells for the most part
is this sufficient for evs
so when we talk about
sorry
when we talk about actually you know
looking at noise so the noise would be
down on the bottom of the left-hand
panel and then you can see your antibody
fluorescence going up
what does this actually look like
this is essentially the stain index your
separation between noise
and antibody signal
is what you're measuring and you
basically want to look at the spread of
that data so the high p here on the
right hand side is basically your
antibody signal on your positive your
positive events and the small
part on the bottom is basically the
background or the noise
so this gives you your stain index so
some people will use stain index
other people will use separation index
and they're very similar and there's a
whole series of papers that describe the
evolution
of these
equations and i would strongly encourage
you to use these equations they they can
really help you make decisions about
your optimal antibody concentration
so that's what it looks like
that's kind of the math
what does it look like when you graph it
so
what i did is i went and i i googled a
lot of the titrations and looked at a
lot of the presentations and essentially
we came up with
there's three classic scenarios you'll
get
your stain or your separate separation
index that kind of look like
michaelis-menten kinetics if anyone can
remember their enzyme kinetics or your
variable dose response here in the
middle
and there are times too when you can get
substrate inhibition where at higher
concentrations of your antibody
the
it looks like the signal starts to come
back down closer to the noise or the
noise goes up and so the separation
between those two uh peaks decreases
so
and we let's talk about some real data
to look at the protocols some do's and
don'ts and how we actually get some real
uh data into this
so we've kind of worked out a sort of a
general scheme that we use to test
all new antibodies that come in or
antibodies that we have
going for different cohorts that we use
the first thing we do is actually screen
for positive samples
so we use a lot of uh primarily
plasma and serum based
human samples
so there's a lot of variability so
it winds up being
for some antibodies you get all or none
responses and some more you get graded
responses but you always want to have a
sample that you can use in order to get
an adequate titration and this will
become more clear in the next slide
your assay design this is something
i really strongly encourage everyone to
do especially if you're starting out at
your uh the beginning of your program
make sure that your titration range is
adequate three concentrations
is not enough you basically want to span
a good range maybe a hundred fold for
your antibody
we always use the manufacturer's
suggested concentration or reaction
volume as 1x and we go from there
typically we do 15 to 30 minutes
incubation time and because we're
designing most of our work for clinics
we always assay at room temperature
room temperatures is designated as 15 to
30 degrees celsius
standardize your dillion and your
dilution depending on the platform
you're using
but most importantly standardize this
protocol for all of your antibody
titrations
if you do that if you can standardize it
then if you have a weird problem that
shows up you can backtrack a lot easier
and kind of figure out where things may
or may not have gone wrong
one thing that we've actually found
extremely beneficial is we actually have
a standard form that we use for
titrations and this works really really
well
uh in terms of screening i'll make a
note here we've used a fasted sample to
analyze cd41a that'll become more
apparent in a couple of slides
execution
if possible
automate it
okay lots of times you can be dealing
with very small volumes of antibody and
antibodies are sticky proteins and they
can stick to the tips of your pipettes
and you know a little bit of
10 20 error can go a long way in the
data
uh we'd like to perform all of our
assays in triplicate with at least
anywhere from 60 to 120 seconds of assay
time on the flow cytometer within the
the paradigm of
we're not in swarm
uh for the for the events and everything
is clean
you also want to make sure that you're
asking enough positive events to
actually get
valid data okay
for the analysis i strongly encourage
people to plot your standing index and
your separation index most times they'll
look pretty similar but there are times
where
they look
weirdly different
plot the mfi your medium fluorescent
intensity of both the positive and the
negative populations
as well plot your positive event
concentration you want to see
you know all of these things that will
educate you as to what the best antibody
concentration you should use will be
uh for these i typically use a mixture
of software packages flow joe histogram
fcs express there's probably a bunch of
other ones out there
these are the ones that we just
typically use
and then finally evaluate
you know use stats and graphing to
evaluate your your analysis not just the
visual
and the beauty of actually standardizing
your your asset design you can pull upon
historical data especially if you're
running the same
antibody titration over the course of a
number of years we've done this for
various groups and it
it can make a big difference if your
samples are sitting in the freezer for a
year or two years
or your antibodies are in the in the
cooler for a couple of years makes a big
difference
so this is just a screenshot of an
example of staining or screening for
positives and negatives so in this one
we typically use what we have here eight
to ten samples that we have for
screening purposes
and this is what we would test uh
various biomarkers for and you can see
that for biomarker one we get we get
three hits biomarker two i'm not getting
really any hits a little smidgen of
population coming up there but not very
much
ball marker 3 is a winner we've got you
know strong hits in every single sample
and they're all nicely uh separated from
the noise and bottom mark 4 i've got a
single
the nice thing about doing this is that
right off the bat you're going to get
positives and negatives
except for biomarker 3 you're we're just
getting all all positives and we can
investigate that later as to
is this an interference or is this
antibody clean is it noise
um
there are also a bunch of controls that
you run
isotype controls uh will give you a
mixed bag of results depending on what
you're you're looking at
you can run them
but there's a lot of literature out
there this is that
they're not as good and matching them up
with your antibody
is challenging sometimes
internally we've been developing a
broader internal negative control for
both plasma and serum and this works for
the majority of samples but we do get
some instances where
it absolutely does not and i'll show you
examples of that shortly
so
when we execute a titration analysis
what kind of data do we do we take
so for to highlight some of these
different effects that i'm going to talk
about i'm basically going to talk about
using cd41a as a
platelet marker and a plate the derived
particle or pdp
marker so since we're using the hip 8
clone for all of these and i've got
conjugates that range from the e450 all
the way down to pe and
apc we always take our product number
the rrid number lot numbers and when
they're expired and most importantly the
stock concentration of each each file
for this experiment i've also used cell
mass green and
some triton x sorry that data didn't
show up here and plasma we have all of
our plasmas categorized and
id'd
de-identified for
privacy
so this experiment was basically to
highlight the effects of the same clone
and different floor force and this
experiment was executed on the same
sample
same day same operator same machine
and it's important to note that
platelet-derived particles are present
in both plasma and serum just because
you've clotted the blood doesn't mean
that you don't have platelet-derived
particles
so what does this look like so this is a
standard microflow cytometry plot
looking at cd41a
and this is a 405 excited fluorophore on
the y-axis and large angle scatter
on the x-axis
so the blue highlights the total sample
are platelet-derived particles
and also intact platelets on the far
right
in the course of of doing microflow it's
also important there are a number of
controls that you need to run to
standardize your equipment
so here i'm just highlighting some of
the
light scatter beads that we use so we've
used a bunch of the apogee beads
i've used exometry beads and i've also
made my own internal mixture of nist
standardized beads ranging from 80
nanometers polystyrene all the way up to
200.
and this is a way to sort of get uh
an idea as to
how small can your machine or your
platform actually resolve
similarly you can do the same for mesf
and for the
for this talk i'm not going to show this
is uh i'm just trying to get into the
antibody titrations but it is important
to standardize your equipment to make
sure that your equipment is actually
behaving the same day-to-day
you need to calibrate and monitor
your machine on a pretty regular basis
so again to adhere to the myself
guidelines you want to make sure that
you're actually looking at vesicles so
this is
again cd41a on the x-axis and cell mass
green on the
y-axis on the far left we have basically
just the sample the categories are here
just below the histograms or the
cytograms just the sample uh the next
one we've got the sample plus the
antibody and you can see
that we're starting to get the cd41a
positive platelets and platelet derived
particles showing up
there's a little bit of green
fluorescence because the big particles
will actually bleed into the green
channel
adding in the cell mass green you get a
significant shift now it's important to
note here that
depending on
what you use
you should titrate your cell mass screen
for
incubation time
final concentration and temperature all
of these things can make a significant
impact also depending on the antibody
you want to make sure that the addition
of cell mass green doesn't interfere
with antibody binding so we've done that
in separate experiments i haven't shown
here but we've noted that there can be
interferences
and the same adding in triton x 100 in
the far right
cytogram you can see that
the data looks completely shifted and
again depending on your sample you may
have to increase the incubation time and
temperature of your tritone x 100
because you may have significantly more
particles than you're used to seeing
especially if you go from
cell culture
to plasma samples or serum samples the
concentration of particles so you just
may need to use more detergent
so we've got the controls all done this
is just a graph to show you here's all
the data
this is what you would look and see on
the screen ranging from the 405 excited
all the way down to
638 excited
so when you plot it what do you see
so essentially
you know
if i replicate the the images i would
get from google
this is what i see
but for
the total
you know the negative population in
microflow cytometry is going to be
predominantly negative or sorry
predominantly the bigger population
by 90 to 95 98
so the populations you're interested in
will always look very very small
this will be your plate that's showing
up uh just as little tiny
hills versus the mountains the plate
that particles you actually don't see
on this scheme and platelets if i gate
just on those you can see them a bit
more clearly and you can see where i've
made the
the cut but again it's really hard to
sort of make a decision
so is this really helpful as opposed to
actually plotting the data so this right
now is our standard whenever we do a
titration this these are the standard
three graphs that
that i look at
on the far left first thing i do is plot
mfi so on the bottom in the clear
circles i get the mfi of the negative
population and you can see that it yeah
it does raise or increase
above the starting concentration a
little bit but we're going from maybe
an mfi of 200 up to about 300 so not not
too much
whereas the positive population
definitely
significantly increases and plateaus
in the middle uh we're looking at the
separation and
stain index and both of these in this
scenario actually agree and
what i do when i plot these and i
haven't identified this but i use a
program called graphpad prism to plot
all of my data so it allows you to do
nonlinear regression
fairly easy and you can compare
different
regression analyses so i typically will
always compare
substrate inhibition to the variable
slope and that takes care of i would say
95 of the analyses
but you can see here that
the index peaks
and then goes down a tiny bit
one thing to note here is that this is
for
the platelet-derived particles and the
separation index is only at around seven
as compared to some or most of the the
cell based protocols where you're
looking at
20s and 50s and hundreds
and again i also look at the
concentration here i've shown you both
counts and concentration and these
similarly plateau
this also tells you when you plot
concentration that you're actually
seeing enough events
to actually make an educated decision
about your optimal concentration
so moving live uh remove next this would
be the actual data for these five floor
fours so i won't spend too much time on
this other than to say that each of them
look
fairly similar
there are differences between the
platelets
your total
and your pdps
you'll see that plateaus look pretty
similar for the separation index uh but
sometimes the graphs may be a little bit
different
you will see that for this particular
one that i've enlarged i can see a
population in each of the cytograms that
shows up in the upper right hand corner
and for this particular analysis
this was some aggregation that we saw
with the actual antibody at high
concentrations
so it's also a way you don't just plot
the data look at the actual cytograms as
well
so i have to thank asia for this graph
because she
after i did the analysis and plotted the
awful antibody contra concentration she
basically they asked me what do you get
the same numbers for your platelets and
your pvps
platelets are basically what i'm using
as a circuit for cells and i didn't see
any difference in these particles
basically these all raised up as soon as
the antibody titration got high enough
valve gave me the same data the pdp's
however
actually did significantly increase and
if you plot them
relative to the conjugate brightness
and
basically what i did for the e450 and
super bright i put in the sort of the
relative brightness of where i expected
them to be
but when you plot them this way it
actually makes sense that as you
increase
the
brightness of your fluorophore you may
see more particles because more
particles are actually getting above
that threshold of detection
now this is where your mesf may come in
and i'll standardize this
but the take-home message for this slide
is basically you know your large
particle detection is going to be less
affected by your
brightness
than smaller particles coming from that
same cell
and again this is sort of one of those
graphs that you have to do i mean if you
titrate your antibody you can save money
in each of these
particular antibodies
we're actually using significantly less
than the vendor
recommended uh concentration so it does
pay to actually literally pay to to
titrate your antibody now there will be
some situations um where you actually
have to use more
the
concentration
so let's move now a little bit about
graphing and presenting your data
so i use a variety of platforms i've
just highlighted them here flow joe and
the
text that i put here there's some
some very good references flo joe
exchange basically talks about using a
r plug-in to automate
the separation or stain index
calculation it works best if your evs
are very well separated from from the
noise
there's a couple of
youtube videos for fcs express
but i will strongly uh suggest you use
the
resources from the university of
wisconsin-madison that has been an
excellent
tool especially if you're new to using
flojo and you just want some help and
guidance moving through that
so what does it look like when you
actually graph oh before i get to that
one thing that i i do want people to
look at is
if you have a situation where your evs
are
[Music]
starting to separate from the noise but
not
you can't quite tell they are the
resolution that you see in some of your
software packages may be hindering that
so i know in flojo it's typically a 512
by 512 uh
sort of scenario
in
fcs express and histogram i can go from
512 to 512 but increase that up to 1024
by 10 24 and that can actually make a
difference especially if your population
is very close to the uh
to the baseline
it's just something to keep in the back
your back your mind
so again how does this start when you're
doing your graphing and flow joe
in panel one you're basically
bringing your data in
making your tables over here this would
be the cd41a so i'm basically making
platelets versus um
i'm sorry no this is not the cd41 that i
did this is something i stole from work
i was doing a couple days ago
but since you bring in your data panel
two shows you sort of the gating
strategy
essentially i gate
as much of the positive and negative as
i can to be as unbiased as possible
from this gating strategy you're going
to then make a table
with different columns in each column
we'll talk about your mfi
and in number four this basically shows
you the
formulas you would use for stain index
and this is all spelled out in
some of the previous uh references sites
i showed and then at the end of it you
can actually generate your table
um
that you can put here in the clipboard
one thing to note with the
um
the tables that you generate if you pop
them into excel you can then use that to
um
orient your data in a way that you want
to for graphing
but i have noticed that this data and
just maybe the way that i've got my
computer set up will give you commas
instead of periods for decimal points
and that can confuse the program
sometimes so you can just go in and
correct those
so taking that data and graphing it
uh some do's and don'ts in in my my
opinion
if it's xy data
concentration you know independent
dependent variable plot it on an xy
graph don't plot it using bar graphs
and i say that because you can
misinterpret
or lose some of the
the information that the data is
providing you
for one thing you know small
ranges in the concentration of your
antibody can actually be skewed because
it'll take up half the graph when it
should only take up you know a fraction
of that
one thing that i i've found with a lot
of colleagues and a lot of collaborators
is when they talk about their their
antibody concentrations that they're
using
as
dilutions
i was strong this is just that in your
standardized protocol you actually use
micrograms per reaction especially if
you standardize the volume of your
reaction that allows sort of you know no
miscommunication you know how much
antibody you need to have per reaction
reaction or test
i also would strongly suggest doing more
than four concentrations i like to use a
wide range so about 100x
and when you look at the data
you know
be your own worst critic look at the the
data that you've plotted and go you know
did i screw something up and if you did
you know take that and move with it and
fix it
this first pass will also tell you if
you need to
include
more
concentrations at a lower range or a
higher range
and again when you plot the data
don't just use the first plot that comes
out on your software take the time to
look at
and change the data so that you get
a really solid analysis of the data and
it
speaks to what the data should be
showing you these are four graphs
showing the exact same data set and all
i've done is i've changed the either the
x or y axis
from linear to log that's all so the
data looks very very different but
you pick the one that
tells you the information that you you
need to actually use to make a decision
so just sort of summarize uh in this
section
why titrate i mean you're looking for
the best resolution of your signal to
noise and you're trying to save money
and have reproducible data
when to titrate
your clones new conjugates new lots new
shipments
weird storage weird data
typically i find just three kinds of
classic data to expect
titrate you know you're going to screen
samples design your experiments execute
the analysis analyze the data and then
evaluate the data
i've shown you some real examples with
cd41 and i know i've gone through this
fast but you guys can go back and look
at the data in more detail later i've
highlighted uh
i really i've highlighted controls for
light scatter and fluorescence and
negative and positive controls
floor for brightness can definitely
impact your detection of small particles
and evs
there's a bunch of different software
packages for analyzing
but more importantly critically evaluate
your data
so i know that cd41 is bit of a cheat
because it's easy and it's going to give
you very clean data so i'm just going to
be a couple of more real examples to
highlight i've de-identified these for
ip purposes
so i'll start off using this one this
was cd
xx and this is a vile blue conjugate
it gave us great titration this is
exactly what i want to see every single
day i don't get to have that that's what
i want to see
this one was great
but it caused issues further down in the
multiplex so we had to move away from
this one
and went to another
405 excited so i tried
a different company
using the super bright 436.
this gave me really nice bright data
but it behaved very differently in this
scenario the background came up
dramatically
and the the curve really showed a
dramatic reduction in concentration and
the index values also showed a similar
sort of like substrate inhibition
so in this one
this was weird
what do you do
so i mean i think the first sort of
go-to is that you need to turn your gain
down or your pmt so we
we set up our gain or our pmt
um
at the beginning so that we get the
minimum amount of noise again this data
same antibody same clone different
companies different conjugates but you
want to set your equipment up at the
beginning so that this is not going to
be a problem and you want to
um i think in this scenario go back and
actually assay some lower concentrations
of the antibody
that's what we did
so another example of easy data this is
an apc
so again
first couple of concentrations starting
with unstained moving up to higher
concentrations of the data just
following the graphs you can see you
know a nice increase in mfi and
concentration kind of plateaus
and our internal negative control here
was nice and clean uh the data look
very similar plateau is nice this is
again this is what i want all the time
this one is a little bit different not
so easy so
similar type of sample
but the data was very diffuse
at most of the concentrations i didn't
get a very nice
tight
group of
evs it was almost as if the antibody
itself was dirty
but the background didn't go up as you
can see by the plot in the mfi graph the
index values
didn't
[Music]
perform as a nonlinear regression it
looked more like a linear regression
which is kind of weird
and of course our internal negative
control down here lit up like a
christmas tree
which occasionally happens
just to show that our
internal negative control was not
universal or is not universal which is
fine we we know that going in
so this this one required more work
so what some other things to to think
about um
there are a lot of other questions that
that we want to talk about and i'm just
gonna try to highlight some of these
your sample complexity and panel
building so cells and evs both
media are very complex
uh you're looking at different parts of
the whole sample
i mean cells have a lot of granularity
and so you can separate some you know
different types of cells simply by
light scatter
evs don't separate that way
you can
maybe separate platelets a tiny bit
but i and i'm saying that with
quotations around them
most evs i would say 99 of eb's don't
separate at all by uh by light
scattering that same scenario
there's a lot of panels for cells for a
lot of different diseases they have been
made and tested and validated over the
years
ev panels for
different diseases don't exist yet
we can look at three to four
biomarkers at a time
i would
i would hazard and that's for physical
reasons and i'll get to these now
shortly
but i think the field is moving in that
way where we'll soon in the next few
years start to have some panels
matrix effects
so if you're titrating an antibody and
you titrated for plasma
can you use that same optimal antibody
concentration for serum
or for urine or csf or any other media
you know what you got to do the
titration and and check it in this
particular case uh plasma and serum
actually behave
pretty similarly and this is with edta
and
sst tubes
urine is different altogether i mean you
have a different concentration of
evs
the ph and
dilutions are going to be different
you're going to be looking at different
concentrations of particles all together
none of and i should say that of all the
data that i've shown you none of these
are with isolated these are simply uh
a small aliquot of the plasma or the
urine or the serum and antibody added
directly these are not enriched with
beads or any other matter if you do
enrich with any beads or stuff like that
the titration is performed exactly the
same way you're just using enriched
particles
so think about your particle size i mean
we've all seen these these uh figures
but it's important to note that you know
as your particles get smaller the number
of receptors that you have available for
interrogation
decreases
that's really important to keep in mind
just like cells
ev analysis you need to balance your
um
expected antigen density with your four
or four brightness
right so you need to look at that as
well small particles
you know they scatter less light
so then also you need to think about
your your triggers so all of this stuff
comes into play
so let's put this into sort of a context
so this is taken from data from
the zeiss campus isn't backed up with
um
data from it from paper which i
apologize doesn't seem to have been
referenced here i will i will follow
that up but this is a nice standard igg
molecule and
here you can actually see
in pretty much approximately the right
size fluorescent proteins attached
synthetic dyes on the bottom
or quantum dots
and you can notice that quantum dots
change in size as you go up
uh in the excitation
for the emission
so this thing that really shows up here
is that you know
the
fluorophore conjugate is actually fairly
big
in relation to
the actual igg molecule
this is pe
it's again just as big as
the the antibody almost
so now let's put this in the context of
your evs and your
your exosomes or evs so this is covered
19
which you know as greeted as anywhere
from 50 to 140 nanometers i think
most people say it's about 100
nanometers so right mid-range
despite protein on top there's about 300
i think
instances of that
that's the dark purple on top of the
liposome looking molecule
the sort of
lighter blue color
would be your antibodies
so now you have to think about the
crowding of
you know your antibody mixtures and the
availability of
just simply accessing
those epitopes
for those antigens
so let's compare that with the cell
so i found this really neat uh paper
in nature immunology um
that basically said
if a human being is the size or scale to
the size of an antibody
then if you take a lymphocyte and spread
it out the total surface area would
cover the entirety of central park in
large parts of
the upper
west side and east side of manhattan
there's a lot of room here for
antibodies to bind different
receptors compared to the crowding
we're going to see on your standard
extracellular visco
so let's also look at your floor for
brightness
so here i've just presented a 3d
analysis looking at the brightness of
your fluorophore
with the excitation
and the emission and i apologize that
this is not
clear it would be
uh excitation have to say if one is
facing or not but you you can sort of
see it going from left to right you'd
have 405 excited and more to the the
right you'd have the 638 um
excited but it shows you another
highlighted like brilliant violet 421 pe
they're bright
compared to fitzy which is kind of right
smack dab in the middle uh of the
diagram as well the sci-fi and the abcs
show up there
so that's just sort of the to put it
into reference now the yellow box that i
put on the bottom
in my experience and others may disagree
but i found that these particular uh
fluorophores are difficult to see on
extracellular musicals and
exosomes whichever you want to call them
small particles
and again i want to emphasize you need
to balance your expected antigen density
with your floor for brightness because
this can have implications for
multiplexing
later
so
what if you don't well if you're unlucky
enough to have uh just a simple primary
antibody with no conjugate and you want
to do a secondary well
take into consideration that you're
actually adding in another antibody now
and all of these different components
move around
so your your crowding becomes even more
complicated on the antibody
more importantly in the context of
titration
a lot more wells you have to titrate
both your primary antibody concentration
and your secondary antibody
concentration
and that's what we want we all want to
do more work
so i'm going to try to rush through this
in on the next few but i just want to
highlight standard flow versus
imaging just as an example so i've
repeated the cd41 assay
it's ran the same controls and got the
same data
and you guys can come back and look at
this i'll just skip to the crucial parts
this would be the the raw data for the
imaging flow
using the imaging flow and compared that
to the microflow standard microflow on
the apogee that we've used
i got the same optimal antibody
titration that they matched
the weird thing was if you look at the
separation index on the standard
microflow it was about
300
for for platelets
on the imaging flow it was
about 2 000 so extremely
elevated and i couldn't figure out what
was going on and then i realized that
because the imaging flow used to see
fluorescence
it was using these particles that were
right at zero so the the calculations
um
basically just artificially inflated the
separation index but i was still able to
get the same uh optimal antibody
concentration
event triggering light scatter versus
fluorescence so i'm just going to
quickly look at the data here you know
on light scatter i like using light
scatter because i like to see the
context unstained samples
up in the top left hand panel you can
see small angle large angle
and then on the bottom beneath that you
can see that there's no positive signal
add in your antibody
light scatter looks the same but your
positive particles show up
in the blue in panel three you can again
see the unstained sample
no particles and hardly anything looks
like a clear white uh screen
now if you look at your sample plus your
fluorescence you can see a little bit of
noise that i've highlighted in the red
there but you do actually start to see
you know your positive signals that's
fine this is just what the data looks
like
moving forward
i cheated a little bit on the way that i
actually gauged the negative population
but i was able to get
the same antibody concentration
regardless of trigger optimal antibody
concentration
concentrations were basically the same
no mfi differences in the positives and
stain that index gave similar but with
different numbers as expected
but i want to sort of raise the question
is this always going to be the case
what if you have a situation where
you're triggering
simply by fluorescence and you have this
scenario where your baseline creeps up
for experienced users this may be
obvious
but if you're new to the field and
you're doing your antibody titration
the blue what blue data here is what you
would get
using light scattered trigger the black
would be what you would get with
fluorescence triggering it looks like an
appropriate graph
your event concentration in the blue
shows what we've seen before
and the black
this looks
acceptable it looks a little bit weird
but it's acceptable
so things to think about
so again just to finish up uh cells and
evs
multiple levels of complexity there's a
whole bunch of the points to think about
in terms of you know don't assume your
matrix is going to be the same think
about your antigen density floor for
brightness probe selection and
multiplexing all these things come
together
um
your optimal antibiotic concentration
should be independent of your flow
platform but your data analysis needs to
be informed i mean your the optimal
concentration should be the optimal
concentration and triggering
i don't care which way you trigger just
as long as you use that triggering in an
informed manner
but for fluorescence triggering what are
you going to use as the negative
population
so hopefully i've touched on the
majority of these
i may have missed some because i
realized i was running long um
but julie uh from miltini actually said
something to me the other day we were
going through this that antibody
titration is an investment it's an
investment in your time your future time
and literally in the success of your
project
i want to really make sure that you
balance theory with your empirical
evidence but most importantly critically
evaluate your data
and with that i will
have a little bit of time for questions
sorry i know that was rushed guys
desmond thank you so much for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live q and a portion of this
webinar and if you have any questions
please ask now just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
and it looks like we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience
our first question desmond is there a
best antibody
conjugate to use for example pe and
brilliant violet 421 are very very
bright should we just use these
uh
you know you always want to use choose
the price floor floor before you can
but typically most of us are going to be
using multiplexes so
a couple things
your your that conjugate may not be
available for your antibody so that may
be the limiting factor um
it could be something very similar but
typically you have to balance your
multiplexing with your choice of
fluorophore
thank you so much and now are you really
suggesting that we should titrate our
antibodies in all of these situations
and the sec there's actually a
three-part question here and is it
really worth it or doesn't it just use
up antibody stocks
my boss really wants to see the
difference between these treatments
so
that's you know actually it's up to you
if you do you don't
as someone who's looked at a lot of data
and a lot of scenarios and just simply
asking the question have you titrated
your antibody
you know if your experiment didn't work
and you didn't titrate your antibody
then i can't believe that there was no
difference between positive and negative
or control and treatment
yeah i i really do i do suggest that you
titrate your antibodies whenever there's
a question that that may may have
changed in any different state
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
desmond how do you calculate index if
there are no separations between the
background and the staining
that's a tricky one so it's almost like
fluorescence triggering or um or not so
typically i would run uh
a bunch of different unstained samples
my
negative control
uh if i'm using isotypes i'll run the
isotypes and look at those and i'll use
all of those
different situations as the place where
i'm going to put my negative population
gate
in a lot of ev analysis you will find
that you
you won't always get a clear separation
and that makes sense these particles are
small
and they're not going to have very many
uh
antibodies actually bound so it may just
simply be not enough signal to get above
the threshold they may be there they
just may be beyond your limit of
detection
thank you so much now aside from
availability do you use a separation
index to determine the chosen
fluorophone for a given experiment
sorry did you assign the game
i said aside from the availability do
you use a separation index to determine
the chosen floor for for a given
experiment
uh i have in the past yes there are
different times when you can use
separation index if you if you think
you're going to have a lot of uh antigen
density
you can say you know what this one's
going to be really good or you can have
situations where you have a population
of your particles that are bigger for
one particular
antibody
versus a second
group that you're looking at within the
same sample that are smaller and you
just sort of balance the dimmer floor
four with the the brighter one on the
smaller particles dimmer 404 on the
bigger particles smaller
brighter fluorophore on the smaller
particles
thank you so much
our next audience number says desmond
you mentioned using microgram per
reaction but why not use microgram per
microliter
that that's fine so i put in microgram
per reaction uh only because our
reaction volumes are standardized
if you're using you know concentration
is definitely the way to go
because we're looking at different
cohorts and
sometimes
different antibody volumes depending on
what we're doing i like to look at
the microgram per reaction and that
allows me to to standardize it and but
if you go back and back calculate with
concentration it it'll balance up
but yes definitely the concentration is
the way to go
make sure you talk about either the
concentration of the antibody you're
adding
or the final concentration in the
reaction volume that's the part you need
to standardize
thank you so much
now our next question is about matrix
effects desmond isn't it the number of
cells you analyze and or the number of
receptors present on each cell that
matter
so i don't understand the question in
relation to the matrix
so
yes you need that you need to have
enough positive stain particles if
you're doing a titration you need to
have enough positive stain particles
to evaluate your titration if you choose
a sample
or a set of samples to titrate your
antibiotic your antibody on and it looks
more like a negative sample as opposed
to a positive sample
then your titration may be completely
skewed
same way if you choose a pocket if you
choose a series of samples that have an
enormous positive
population versus the majority of your
samples having moderate to low
populations
you may be skewing in the other way you
want to choose your screening samples
to be reflective of the majority of
samples you're going to look at and i
don't know if i've answered that
question uh i can follow up within one
month further clarification
wonderful thank you so much
now what would be your strategy to
titrate antibody if you know that your
satiny gives you two distinct positive
populations which population would you
use for titration
so i've tried to highlight that with the
uh platelets
and platelet-derived particles in the
cd41 data
there are times when
it gives you the same uh
same optimal antibody concentration
if you have two different populations
the question is
you know is there something in your
if you're using cell culture your
unconditioned media that's giving you
protein aggregates is one population
protein aggregates
are they both viable um
the vesicles there's a lot of questions
to
answer there you can actually just do a
gating strategy and see if those
populations titrate the same or
differently
but that's that's a tough one that you
will probably come across
thank you so much and again thank you
for these great questions coming in
what eternal internal controls have you
used for the titration desmond
so we have built a lot of different
types of internal controls we screen a
lot of patients
and a lot of
normal healthy controls because we're
looking at disease versus healthy
we also have uh in place of way to
actually uh build our own internal
controls i've used isotypes a bunch of
different types from different companies
everything that i can think of i've
tried
your choice of negative control is tough
uh you know building a set for your
particular antibodies is not trivial
excuse me not trivial because it's not
only finding a negative population but
it's fine for a negative sample finding
a negative sample or a positive sample
that you can use as positive and
negative controls throughout your set of
experiments
that's not it's not trivial
thank you desmond and we have time for a
couple of more questions desmond what do
you think is the maximum number of
antibodies you can multiplex for ev slow
cytometry
you know what i've done
three is my go-to
i've done four
it is really
you you really have to pay attention to
the samples you're looking at
compensation with evs
is
not quite standardized for small
particle flow right yet
and that does make it uh
extremely challenging would i do five or
six
or seven
um
i don't know if there's enough data out
there yet to say that we can use the
same strategy with
evs as we do with cell where we can
negatively gate
i don't know if that data is sound
enough yet to actually do that kind of
extended panel design
thank you so much and finally our last
question that we have time for today
which is the best titron 100x
concentration recommended and
what about time of incubation
you know what that's uh
that's an empirical one
you got to titrate it
that's that's a really good question uh
if you find you've got cell culture
titrate your tritone x 100 concentration
start at a high one of even five percent
you're going to find with different
detergents that you're going to have a
critical micelle concentration so you
could actually make more particles
change the temperature change your
incubation time
all of these things influence the amount
of solubilization you have
so it's one of these things i mean
titrating your
membrane dyes titrating your detergents
all of these things inform you about
your samples and your actual assays if
your samples are all coming from
fasted patients versus fit patients
patients
versus cell culture
the stock concentration of particles
within those samples as well as the
types of particles within those samples
are all very different and all of those
will affect the way that your detergents
work
and again think of it if you're
trying to solubilize a very cold thing
it's not going to that's not going to
solubilize and cold very well
desmond thank you very much for your
presentation today and for your time
would you like to provide any closing
remarks to our audience before we go
uh
just the last thing i mean
antibody titrations can save your
project
it's going to be a question that your
reviewers are going to ask they should
ask
critically evaluate your data try to be
your own worst critic or your own
harshest critic and
that typically will save you
lots of pain in the end but there's a
lot of us out there that have done a lot
of these types of experiments so
that's why our emails are typically
available and ask us questions
absolutely and i thank you again desmond
for your time and for your important
research i'd also like to thank lab
roots today and our sponsor miltoni
biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone and stay safe bye